good news for the Kardashians that's
right oh yeah Kylie Jenner's baby
daughter has made her debut on snapchat
at one month old one month old yeah in
the Kardashian world that is known as a
late bloomer taking her a while to get
started
she's an underachiever someone went yeah
[Applause]
could have been sarcastic or just really
well said sir well says it sounds the
same at home who knows and who cares
hey this is big news from about SeaWorld
the CEO of SeaWorld has stepped down
yeah
step down yeah yeah he's gonna be
getting a ten million dollar retirement
package if he can jump up and catch it
with his mouth tore my crotch in an
interview this week in an interview
everyone's talking about this Barbra
Streisand revealed that she cloned her
favorite dog twice she cloned her
favorite dog twice barber said I
couldn't help myself
he was delicious now thank you
thank you thank you you like that one
there's a woman there can I have that
one please can I have that joke I didn't
think we would do that joke but I
thought the crowd I thought we got away
with it and it's going to this woman who
says she's been watching me since a year
before she was born
good luck with that joke and the real
world I had to hear this the number one
reason that prospective applicants are
rejected from the show The Bachelor did
you know what it is
herpes that's a true story the number
one reason that contestants are reject
on The Bachelor is herpes yeah
apparently you can't get on the show if
you don't have it
in other news it's kind of a crazy story
the Las Vegas Airport has asked
passengers to dispose of their marijuana
in a special box before you gonna pay
for special box yeah in a related story
at a Las Vegas Airport today Willie
Nelson was found hiding in a box
you have a whole monologue now you can
do that anywhere anywhere you want and
it'll do as least as well as this one
did yeah she just is she gets some fake
building she can have a talk show yeah
exactly
I'm gonna be driving out tonight and I'm
gonna find those cards in the trash ever
tell you that story yes yeah when I
first got famous like in 1993 I went to
an event and someone someone person
because I had been on the air for like
eight seconds it's like a 1993 saw me
and asked for an autograph and then a
lot of other people were like look I
must be famous and they all wanted one
and then later after the event I went
outside and I saw at least nine of them
in the gutter no that's a good story it
humanized me it kept me humble right
right without that you would be a
monster yeah
you